so I had a question with someone that
wanted to know what are some of the
differentiating factors between symptoms
from a potential heart attack versus
symptoms from actual heartburn that's a
good question because they're very very
similar in fact some of the symptoms are
identical both will give you like a cold
clammy type feeling both will produce
nauseousness both can cause the burning
pain all right so now let's talk about
the differences well typically if you
have left pain pain it goes down the
left arm it's going to be a heart attack
but not always because sometimes if
you're having heartburn or indigestion
it can produce pain on the left side but
it's rare also heart attacks more likely
will come from a stress event or
exercise but not always sometimes you
may get heart attack symptoms after you
eat but as a side note you should know
that there are over 300,000 non cardiac
visits to the hospital every single year
so obviously these people had either
heartburn or some type of digestive
problem that's producing these symptoms
it wasn't related to the heart
now with heartburn you're gonna see this
after the meal but not always because if
you have an ulcer that's causing this
heartburn you could have it when you're
not eating when you're laying in bed you
can have heartburn so these are just
general guidelines typically with
heartburn you're gonna have more
bloating which you're not necessarily
gonna have with a heart attack so that's
different you may have acid reflux so
acid that comes up in your esophagus so
that's gonna be more related to
heartburn you may have more burping
belching but one really good indication
to know that it's more heartburn is that
if you take apple cider vinegar and some
water let's say you take two tablespoons
in a glass of water and you drink this
down and your heartburn goes away well
then chances are it's more likely
heartburn now as far as food goes the
history of what a person ate let's say
you ate a lot of sugar
junk food well that could create this or
this so you really can't differentiate
based on a history of what someone ate
but one of the best things that you can
take as far as a supplement to prevent
heart attacks especially angina is
vitamin E a complete complex I'm talking
about the combination of not just a
cough or also all of them but
tocotrienols together as one unit that's
not only good for angina the actual
cramping of the muscle that could be
coming from the muscle itself but it's
also good for problems in the artery
because you need vitamin E as an
antioxidant to prevent the breakdown or
the tissue so about a minute you can
actually prevent the build-up of plaque
okay so vitamin E is important and of
course the healthy version of Kido low
carb and in a minute fasting very very
important as far as heartburn goes you
want to incentivize stomach you want to
take out the cider vinegar you want to
take things like betaine how to chloride
before you eat like you could probably
take them in pills take like four or
five before you eat for a few months to
acidify the stomach and then of course
healthy keto and ifr going to be
essential for that alright thanks for
watching so if you want more knowledge
on how to create a healthy body
subscribe now and get daily
notifications